foreign
track is the US's only Barrier Reef
system it's about 300 miles long and
what we saw over the last few decades is
an incredible decline in Coral cover
what we're looking at is the potential
loss of an entire ecosystem which we've
never experienced in human history and I
don't think anyone wants to find out
what that would mean if we had a
complete collapse of our coral reef
ecosystems
my name is Jessica Levy and I am the
director of restoration strategy for the
coral restoration Foundation the core
restoration Foundation is a
not-for-profit headquartered in the
Florida Keys so here we are in one of
core restoration foundation's offshore
Coral nurseries it's about an acre and a
half wide it's the largest offshore
Coral Nursery in the world and it's a
spectacular site to visit
the restoration process starts in the
very original sense with collections of
natural corals these are corals that are
at risk to some event so we actually go
out to our local reefs and harvest from
them and instead of return visits to the
wild we use that Coral in a nursery
system where that original collection is
allowed to grow over time and as it
grows you take subsequent cuttings from
that original collection and you produce
more and more corals
the main structure that CRF uses and
pioneered is what's known as the Coral
Tree it's a very simple structure that
floats in the water column it's made of
PVC and fiberglass in our nurseries in
particular we have upwards of 500 of
these Coral structures and the corals
are actually suspended on those
structures themselves so you'll see our
divers swimming through this Forest of
coral trees some of the main activities
that they're likely to do in a nursery
is cleaning removing algae and biofouls
and any other organisms that have kind
of grown on those structures and might
compete with that coral for living space
we use very simple materials to work on
our trees we use wire brushes or a
chisel to clean the structures
themselves we use Clippers to actually
cut the coral or cut the monofilament
line that the coil is suspended from the
tree with
while you can work pretty heavy-handed
with the trees themselves corals are a
living animal it's a very thin layer of
animal tissue so we're very gentle when
we're working with the coral itself
typically when we suspend a coral
fragment it's maybe a couple of
centimeters long or wide and then after
about nine months it'll grow to about
the size of a football at which point
that is an appropriate size what we call
Reef ready and able to be moved to a
nearby restoration site we will go to a
structure go to a coral tree and clip
from those individual corals there this
takes advantage of a process known as
asexual fragmentation essentially making
clones of your original your individual
and we fragment from the corals on the
trees we'll move them to either new
trees and resuspend them to continue to
grow and take advantage of that Nursery
phase or we'll fragment from the
existing stock and go through a process
of harvesting so we'll go to these trees
themselves and we'll actually collect
corals from those nurseries those corals
are then moved onto our boats and they
sit in sea water and then they'll be
transported to a nearby restoration site
to begin the process of out planting
once we're at an out plant site our
divers enter the water someone from the
boat hands them crates of corals those
divers then swim down
once we're at the reefs the first step
in the process is to find your out plant
site so this is an area that's
relatively hard bottom open lots of
space and available substrate to work
with a diver than clears The Reef area
where that Coral is going to eventually
be secured what we look for is white
crisp Rock it's basically Limestone or
old Coral
we then mix our two-part epoxy and this
almost like pulling Taffy motion until
it's one single clay or or putty will
take a small pinch of that epoxy that
we've just mixed push that into the reef
substrate itself and then gently place
the coral on top of that point that
we've cleared and that epoxy will harden
and have attached that Coral to The Reef
itself we'll then pretty much step and
repeat the process until an individual
diver has gotten 100 corals down or
until a team of divers has gone anywhere
from three to eight hundred corals done
in a single day
these corals are placed in clusters of
about 50 to 70 individuals they're
placed in clusters of the same genetic
material so they're essentially clones
of their names
over time these corals start to Branch
out and they start to touch their
neighbors and they start to fuse and
what happens is they create this one
large Thicket so this Thicket has all
these in and outs that allow small fish
to duck in and hide from predators it
allows for a lot of inverts to thrive
there as well this is the structure that
we really want to produce the important
part is promoting that genetic diversity
on the reef site
our Nursery program on an annual basis
produces probably about 40
000 brief ready corals the reality is is
restoration is never a one-off it's not
something you do and then pretty much
ever walk away from there probably will
always be work to do and the reason is
is it's because we have not
removed all the pressures and the stress
that our reefs face today and until we
fully remove all these pressures we're
still going to have the need for
restoration restoration right now kind
of works to keep Pace with that loss to
keep Pace with an ecosystem still kind
of going even if it's maybe considered
to be treading water it's still about
keeping the system alive because if we
don't do anything now there's not going
to be anything left to work with this is
not just a Florida problem reefs around
the world are facing the exact same
challenges and scale of decline in the
last 30 years Global coral reefs have
declined by 50 this has a cascading
effect on a lot of different aspects for
example 25 of marine life depends on a
coral reef system at some point in their
life history whether they live there
full time or they migrate to at some
point point in their life cycle
additionally coral reefs are part of a
healthy ocean system about 70 percent of
the oxygen that we as humans breathe
comes from our oceans Florida in
particular sits at about 98 decline
which means about two percent Coral
cover left which although drastic and
terrible it's better than zero we don't
want to find out what happens when we
hit zero it's easy to talk about the
impact of a degraded coral reef to a
local community that has a very
one-to-one connection the reality is it
affects all of us whether you live on a
coastline or you live somewhere where
you've never even seen the ocean to
begin
foreign